Speaker 1: Jon Stewart has a he has a pretty good
new program, I have to tell you. The thing he did
in the middle there after The Daily Show,
it wasn't so good. This new thing is very,
very good. And Jon Stewart has done some
extraordinary interviews recently. Jon Stewart
interviewed Mark Brnovich. He's the attorney
general of Arizona. And he interviewed him
about all sorts of different claims of so-called
election irregularities, fraud, etc.. And this
is just a little bit of a preview. The full
interview is going to be out over the weekend,
I believe. Take a look at this. And as good as
a job is, Jon Stewart does focus on the lack of
serious thinking that Mark Brnovich displays here.
Speaker 2: Right now we have about, I think,
almost 20 criminal cases related to the 2020
election out of 4 million votes. You know what?
I'm talking FOX, John, but the reality is, is
there are millions of people not only in Arizona,
but people throughout this country that think the
election is stolen. There's people that believe
in angels. But that doesn't mean you launch
an investigation that angels change ballots.
Speaker 1: That's a really important thing
because all these MAGA people that I interview
and they say, we we just want to know for
sure. We just want a forensic audit which
they can never define. We want this, that, and
the other thing so that we can really be sure.
The level of investigation needs to correlate
to the level of evidence for irregularities.
And again, when this guy says we have 20
instances that we're investigating here,
20 cases out of 4 million votes, it doesn't
warrant the degree of spending and resource
allocation that they have been doing.
Speaker 2: But that bit of a tautology,
when you have a former president spreading rumors
to his supporters, for instance, Trump can say.
74,000 mail in ballots received that were
never mail magically appear in ballots. 168,000
fraudulent ballots printed on illegal paper.
36,000 ballots illegally cast by non-citizens.
Now, the truth is, none of that was real when it
first came out. The cyber ninjas said Joe Biden
won Arizona. And then they got a lot of pushback
when they started hedging and hawing. And the
next thing you know, people were like, well,
Brnovich needs to do something about it. And
then it was like, You've responded by doing things
about it. What I've done is said, You're still
investigating. We've run it. We've run a lot of
the stuff on ground. And when I when you get it to
ground, will you come out and say, Donald J. Trump
is wrong? The election in Arizona was fair. Not
stolen and not fraudulent. I have always been a
straight shooter. And once. No, all, once. All the
facts and evidence for John McCain. Come on, man.
I'm telling you, I have found no evidence that the
election in Arizona was fraudulent or stolen
from Donald Trump. Donald Trump lost Arizona.
Period. I've said that from the very beginning.
There have been isolated incidences thus far that
we've identified and we are prosecuting. Yes, we
still have some active investigations going on.
But people can draw their own conclusions.
Speaker 1: No, no. How can you draw
your own conclusions about facts?
Speaker 2: We know people cannot draw their
own conclusions. That's the point of the law.
Yeah, it is. Law is that you have facts, right.
And you have fiction. Right. The fact is, the
election in Arizona was well-run, not fraudulent,
and not stolen from Donald Trump, according to
even your investigation. I have never said why is
it so hard to just say yes to that? I just I guess
because I've spent my entire most of my career as
a prosecutor and we still have some ongoing cases.
Speaker 1: But he could say up to this point,
I have found no legitimacy to any of the claims.
Speaker 2: So in your mind, you still feel like
after all this, you're going to discover now a
concerted effort to steal the election from Donald
Trump and that it was fraudulent? Is that what
you're saying? No, that's not what I'm saying.
So why can't you say the election in 2020 was
not stolen or fraudulent? I will tell you this.
As I said, this is blowing my mind. Really?
Speaker 1: Yeah, it is mind blowing. And this
is not some random kook. I mean, he's a kook.
But what I mean is it's the attorney general
of Arizona, and it should be it it's
very scary that even he can't just say
it's over. It's over. There was
nothing here. One other thought.
One of the lines they continue to use is we need
to investigate because a lot of people aren't
confident that it was all on the up and up. But
the reason that those people aren't confident is
because of lies told to them by those who want an
investigation. Right. Trump goes, We can't trust
the results. I really want Arizona ballot dumps,
toilet ballots, ballots and sandwiches, ballots
with barbecue sauce that is not not native to the
United States, you know, all this crazy stuff.
So people go, Wow, we really need to investigate.
Then Trump goes, Look, the people want an
investigation. Yes, but they want it because of
the lies you've told them and it becomes circular.
This is going to be a really good interview. I
look forward to seeing the full thing and you can
see the clip I played today on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.